what are we doing in this neighborhood
come on this place is in our price range
besides i mean people say the
neighborhood's turning around
it's jordan and kira we're here to view
the apartment at three
[Applause]
oh my bad i had this homeless crackhead
trying to set up house in here yesterday
almost had to beat his ass man but y'all
ain't got nothing to worry about cause
anybody try to get up in here
i will murder them let me give y'all the
tour
all right so we got these vintage
windows they've been here as long as the
building's been here
[Music]
hey hey you look i see you out there
you get out that car and i will murder
you
that's what i thought the prolonged loot
roll on my nephew craig
you're a good kid he's no crack though
it's uh just in case you're back all
right i filed a serial number off there
so if you got to shoot anybody
just make sure to wipe your fingerprints
off this month
oh come on y'all ain't gonna bite you
brand new cupboards i put the contact
paper in myself here so y'all don't get
no germs
i thought craig was rolling back i ain't
getting shot by this
twice damn while we down here check this
out
original hardwood floor from when the
building was built
check out this green brother that is
craftsmanship
anyway come on
that is paint is all new
oh okay this
this happened after i had painted funny
story
we got crackheads in this neighborhood
and one of them living right next door
here right
and one day he was smoking crack just
went looney tunes and mistook his nine
millimeter that's a pistol honey
for the remote control but don't worry
you ain't never gonna see him again
ain't nobody ever gonna see him again
plus i'm gonna put a fancy little hook
in there and turn it into a hat rack
now let's take a look at his bedroom
what up i ain't found this place first
found it man i own this place can y'all
give me a second
i'm gonna cut you with my sword cane
so that's gonna be first month of last
month right one must secure the deposit
i'll get the paperwork started
okay baby let's hit this rock real quick